بثت قنوات تيليجرام الروسيه تسجيلا بصوت
اللواء ايفان بوبوف قائدي وحده الجيش
الروسي في زابولوجيا يعلن فيها اقالته من
منصبه لقوله الحقيقه وكذا انه اقيل من
منصبه في يوم واحد بعد ان اوضح في تقرير
له جميع القضايا الاشكاليه الموجوده في
الجيش من حيث العمل القتالي والدعم من
جانبها لم تعلق وزاره الدفاع على هذه
المعلومات حتى الان بينما تجري عمليه
التحقق من حقيقه المقطع الصوتي
من نادونيسك ينضم الينا مراسل الجزيره
امين نادر غامي امين ما المزيد الذي ورد
في هذا المقطع الصوتي وايضا كيف يبدو
التعامل الروسي حتى الان مع هذه الاخبار
في الحقيقه حول ايفان بوبوف كانت هناك
معلومات في وقت سابق وتحديدا بعد
محاوله التمرد العسكري التي قادها كانت
حينها بعض وسائل الاعلام الروسيه التي
تحدثت عن اقاله عدد من
الجنرالات الروس ومن بينهم ايفان
بالمناسبه قائد الجيش الثامن والخمسين
التابع للمنطقه الجنوبيه العسكريه في
روسيا وهو ضمن ذلك الجيش الذي
يقاتل في جبهه زباروج طبعا كانت هناك
انباء تحدثت فيما سبق عن ان
بوبووف لربما تم اقالته بهذا السبب لكن
هذا الفيديو الذي انتشر وبالاحرى التسجيل
الصوتي الذي نشر امس والذي لا صحه ولا
تاكيد لصحته حتى الان اقل من خلاله بان
سبب الاقاله يعود الى انه رفع تقارير عن
نقص كبير في المعدات وفي اجهزه الاتصالات
وغيرها من الاسلحه في جبهه زباروجيا التي
يقودها وذلك بحسب قوله لم يعجب رئيس هيئه
الاركان الظاليري دراسي بدوره رفع تقريرا
الى وزير الدفاع
وتمت اقالته بعد يومين من ذلك طبعا كانت
هناك ايضا معلومات كثيره قد تحدثت عن ان
هذه الاقاله اكيده لكن وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه لم تصدر اي بيان تتحدث فيه سواء
عن اقاله الجنرال او غيره من القاده
العسكريين خاصه وان هناك لبس حتى الان
ايضا يحوم حول
نائب قائد العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في
اوكرانيا
الجنرال طبعا كل هذا كان بعد محاوله
الت